i'm re how do you rehearse for 45
minutes in general
in chunks or how i personally
rehearse for 45 minutes and this could
also be used as like the template for
how i prepared for my comedy special
taping
is i made a set list of all the jokes i
want to do
and from beginning middle and end of how
i intend
to perform that 45 minute set and then
i'll go back
and rehearse and rehearsing could be if
i'm on the road on the way to the gig
i'll just rehearse while i'm driving
just word for word
how am i planning to deliver this on
stage word for word
and i like to rehearse with distractions
so i like to rehearse
with music on the background or i like
to rehearse while doing something else
because i feel like if you're on stage
and you get distracted you've rehearsed
distracted
so you're able to kind of not react to
that distraction as much it doesn't
throw you off your
game and i'm flexible with the order as
well so
as i'm rehearsing if what i thought i
was gonna put
in the second half of the set now as i'm
rehearsing it fits better in the
beginning half i'll move it up there and
i just
kind of have like a set list and then i
make notes next to that set list
and it's just a constant refining
process but before my comedy special
i had a set list i went out on the road
worked out the set a lot
and it was just in my hotel rooms
reciting it rehearsing it like a script
basically
but it does break down into basically
like what is all the material i have
and then what is a like a cohesive
story or a cohesive order for these
jokes to weave one into the other
it could be based on theme uh you know
it could be based on
you know topic or style or what segway's
into what
you know they may not always be in the
same theme but maybe they flow together
better
that way it's kind of what's going to
help you to deliver it the most
naturally
but it is a process it is a process my
friend and it really starts with
what are all the jokes i want to do what
order do i want to do them in
and then rehearsing them over and over
and over again
hey hop brother and sister and if you
enjoyed this comedy tip
subscribe to this youtube channel and go
join
our facebook group to have your
questions answered live
on next week's q a